I'm not allowed to climb this Tower I
did ask but not only does climbing this
need proper training and safety
equipment it's also a protected Historic
Site the folks in charge are
understandably a bit cautious but while
I can't go up there the camera and you
can this is a Moonlight Tower here in
Austin Texas and it's one of the last
surviving Municipal lighting Towers
anywhere because if you're lighting up a
city to keep people safe at night why
have thousands of small lamps down every
street when you could have just a few
very bright and very high each Tower was
intended to provide light equal to that
of natural Moonlight in an area 1500 ft
from the base of the Tower and that is
light by which somebody could read the
face of their watch these Lighting
systems were all throughout the Midwest
and all throughout the West when these
towers were installed in 1894 they used
carbon Arc lamps the first practical
electric lights those lamps were
literally controlled electrical arcing a
constant spark shooting through the air
between two carbon electrodes these days
if you seeing that kind of harsh white
light at this scale it's usually because
there's a fault with something big and
electrical and there's a short in the
system this was the same effect just
deliberate the catch is that the
electrodes on carbon Arc lamps are
steadily vaporized wearing down as
they're worn Away by the spark so they
burn out quickly and the city had to pay
someone to climb every Tower every day
to replace the lamps the City of Austin
electric utility and as we know it today
Austin Energy started with the Moonlight
Towers every night a utility employee
would go up through this elevator pulley
system through the middle of the Tower
and go light these carbon Arc lamps this
pulley system there's this little thing
for the employee to stand in and then
you have workers on the ground who are
hoisting him up they're going up
potentially 165 ft in the air I don't
know when hard hats came into play but
when you look at older pictures right
our safety equipment is not as it is
today so then in the 1920s they switched
to incandescent buls and in 1936 it was
the mercury vapor lamps and today we're
using LED bulbs and it's a little bit
easier to get up there and exchange the
parts so we're using cranes and bucket
trucks to get up to make those changes
if ever there was a subject designed for
vertical video it's this one most cities
took their towers down as electric
street lighting became possible for some
unknown reason Austin never got down to
it but they've not all been preserved
there's only about a dozen towers still
standing not all of those are in the
same location as they used to be and in
1993 the city took them all apart
refurbished them and put them back up
again as for what they look like when
they're switched on well for that we'll
need to wait until after Sunset Austin
is the only city in the United States
that still has functioning Moon Towers
before the Moonlight Towers were put up
around town it was dark moon could only
do so much and so it really changed
people's lives I think it allowed them
to keep businesses open after dark which
would increase Commerce people could
enjoy themselves with friends and family
and also get home safely Moonlight
Towers were the only game in town for
light after dark you know in in parallel
with the moon itself of course and these
towers clearly work because well look at
me I've got a shadow although admittedly
I am standing right next to it the name
Moonlight Towers isn't just poetic 31 of
these towers were spread around what was
then a much smaller and lower City
before skyscrapers came along that meant
that except for some dark Corners most
of the town would be lit up as if there
was a full or maybe a half moon not that
bright but enough that you could see
your way around hence Moonlight Tower
it's artificial Moonlight although turns
out there's not much evidence for that
name being used until the mid 20th
century when historical preservation
became fashionable and these towers
became an icon of Austin they were not
called Moonlight Towers from the
beginning the Austin
newspapers just called these the towers
there were no other Towers
first reference that I found in a
newspaper to these being called
Moonlight Towers was 1938 in the early
1960s the mass head of the Austin
newspaper had the phrase as Austin as
the phrase changed each day where the
newspaper was comparing itself to other
icons in the city of Austin and in July
1962 the mass head said as Austin as
Moonlight Towers they have become a
symbol of Austin and every holiday
season one of those Moonlight Towers in
zulker park gets used to put up hundreds
and hundreds of bulbs of lights that
look like a holiday tree and you go and
you spin around and you look up and you
get dizzy and you feel like Austin is
just the best place to
be there are modern versions of these
towers for places like giant parking
lots sometimes it is just better to
stick a big light on a pole in most
cases though modern lighting is a much
better choice because every street got
wired up to the grid anyway although
that does mean in the 21st century it's
difficult to imagine what a city lit
Just By Moonlight Towers would feel like
these days there's too much other light
around from every house every building
on a night with low Cloud the sky glow
from light pollution can be brighter
than the old Towers would be at least
right and they would be at a distance
these aren't Street lighting anymore
they're historic artifacts kept running
because well because the people of
Austin like
them